[Musique]
c'est de ce journal à présent dossier
consacré je vous le disais les titres
aux nouveaux pauvres une notion récente
que l'on trouve de plus en plus souvent
évoquée dans les journaux
surtout depuis qu'un récent conseil des
ministres tout entier a été consacrée au
thème de la pauvreté
les nouveaux pauvres ne sont ni des
clochards des zonards ils sont 300
milles en ile de france trois cent mille
personnes pour qui on évoque à chaque
fois le chômage
l'analphabétisme la maladie la
délinquance nous allons voir ce soir le
premier volet d'une enquête réalisée par
philippe vilamitjana et christophe
germain
une enquête qui commence à 15 km de
paris un voyage parmi les pauvres
saisissant
est ce que vous n'avez pas et que vous
aimeriez avoir par exemple vélo par
exemple pour vous avoir un vélo et qu'on
ne peut pas voir ce que ça coûte trop
cher qu'est ce que vous faites pour vous
amuser ici ben je dis je bonjour
élastique pas différent et puis s'il
voulait à paris souvent on va à ce mal
qui colle pour quoi faire
voilà on garde ici liban yahoo semble
loin non paris finalement 13 dans un f5
une cité hlm de la banlieue
une famille nombreuse et isoler les
voisins ne parle pas depuis toujours en
vie dans les dettes
ici en ne jouant jamais les deux les
petits manche avant les grands faute de
place on dort les uns avec les autres
entassés les enfants vont à l'école mais
ils savent à peine lire et écrire
le père et par type la mère ne travaille
pas les espoirs en les fondant
morissette qui fera plus tard de la
comptabilité
pour l'instant on vit avec les moyens du
bord
vous travaillez vous madame vous avez
déjà travaillé quatre ans qu'est ce que
vous faisiez est aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce travail et la vie est
difficile pour vous ça va et qu'est ce
que vous faites pendant la journée je
fait quatre ans que je réfute
pourquoi c'est vrai que j'ai des ulcères
à la jambe droite
j'ai été repéré du dollar et du cas du
coeur on m'a mis un petit jeu peut vite
vous avez une pension alors pour
l'instant j'attends les résultats de des
papiers à la vie est difficile pour moi
ouais comme leur travail il réussit là
je peux pas faire qu'est ce que vous
faites pendant la journée
marin la plupart du temps je regarde la
télé vous avez un enfant je crois nous
deux enfants un garçon et une fille et
vous êtes mariés non séparés
vous travaillez en ce moment non vous
voudriez travailler oui qu'est-ce que
voudriez faire femme de ménage comme un
grand quine
so donnera un salaire de plus dans la
maison c'est ça oui ça me reda chez soi
des chaises sur la dictature chaussures
allant sur la parole aux personnes ne
travaillent donc seuls quelques ménages
au noir ce sont les allocations
familiales et l'aide à l'enfance qui
constituent les ressources de la famille
5000 francs par mois pour treize
personnes 2000 francs de loyer les
démarches pour trouver un logement ou un
travail sont longues et fastidieuses et
la plupart du temps sans résultat alors
on se résigne le temps passe la vie
aussi est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour
vous allez vous en sortir
je voudrais bien souvent sorti valeur
soit eux déménagent à voir les moins
chers et plus petits vont s'en prendre
parce que sinon je me retrouve tous les
jours
vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste
pour votre famille
ça veut dire quoi mais vous avez bon
espoir en l'avenir ou au contraire vous
avez lâché des hespérides enfants mon
espoir mais je crois que
je sais
[Musique]